good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday welcome
to the latter half of the week
congratulations we did it it's the
latter half of the week
what is that from congratulations class
of 2004. we did it that's like hurtful
that you would even ask oh okay sorry
it's from Legally Blonde and if you
don't know that I'm surprised you found
our podcast but welcome honestly that
movie made me want to be valedictorian
so that I could make a speech and be
like congratulations class of 2012. we
did it but was L valedictorian no she
was just the chosen speaker because
everybody loved her because she won the
big case her freshman year Miss
Congeniality yeah I think that's what it
was there's like I mean she's really
bright and wonderful and we love Elle
but she wasn't the valedictorian I feel
like she was
no I don't think so I think she was just
the star pupil because like she got
Brook Windham off and she cracked the
case
but I don't think at Harvard Law you get
chosen at graduation unless you're
academically special
agreed that's different from
valedictorian
I don't know if I agree with that sound
off in the comments was L Woods a
valedictorian of Harvard Law School
let us know
um how you doing Jax happy Thursday I'm
doing good I'm so glad that it's
Thursday it's couldn't be a better time
for a Thursday you know it's such a
blessing it is a blessing and we just do
have to acknowledge the space that we're
in because it could have been Monday it
could have been Tuesday it could have
been Wednesday and instead it's Thursday
and for that I am grateful me too I'm
also just like jittery this morning
because busy busy obviously podcast host
Mogul tomorrow officially like I'm back
on tour and I have been off the stage
since May
just thinking about the fact that you
have to get back on stage because that's
why you left Florida and it's like did
she even do her show yet no no I know
and I'm like feeling like Rusty
um so I have a lot of work to do today
after the show is up and posted
because I'm going to West Hampton
tomorrow I'm glad it's like a local show
I don't have to fly anywhere it's a
great way to ease back into the tour
life the life on the road So Glamorous
um so if you're in Long Island New York
tomorrow on Long Island sorry people
from Long Island like I hate when you
say in Long Island they'll be okay
they'll be totally fine
on Long Island in West Hampton tomorrow
night for a show Friday night it'll be
fabulous at the West Hampton Performing
Arts Center because I'm an artist and
that's what we've learned I feel like in
the last few weeks your artistic Nature
has really shown through and it's an
honor to be in the presence of such an
artist wow did you sleep good I slept
all right when I slept
um not the best honestly but not your
best work no not the worst because like
the worst would be like up every hour uh
not the best but I went to sleep earlier
than usual because I was like I need to
find time to catch up on my Z's because
I'm not well I need time to find I need
to find time to catch up on Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills I started
catching up this morning because once
again I woke up before my alarm and I'm
actually loving that by the way like
having some extra time I watched an
episode and a half but overall it was
four episodes behind so I'm still like I
barely have made a dent we just wrapped
up Christmas and I don't know what
you're up to but I cannot remember a
time in recent memory where Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills gave us so
much holiday content I feel like they
let the ladies off and then we see them
in January yeah I also
I'm we haven't mentioned it in a while
and I was hoping I could just like get
away with not watching for even longer
and what's interesting is like of course
we get real housewives fatigued but I've
always felt like it's really important
for us to watch those shows because
that's such a big part of the show is
recapping those shows and it's like our
content would be cut in like half if we
don't watch TV and do TV Recaps and it's
like we're fine no but there's also TV
besides the Real Housewives right like
Southern Charm is on right now and it's
really like and you guys know I love
Southern Charms so it's really just for
like lack of time and now I can't really
catch up without taking a whole day
um and I just assume that there would be
a real dearth of content for us to talk
about if we ever stop doing TV Recaps
I'm not saying this is the end of TV
Recaps but right now it's just not
happening and I'm pleasantly surprised
that the episodes are just as long
there's just as much to talk about yeah
yeah no I was surprised obviously the
last few weeks have been bad for TV
Recaps because we were changing Studios
you were moving like life just got in
the way
um and I thought there would be like a
mass outcry of people and no one like
there's been a few people who are like
TV Recaps but I felt for a long time the
shows that we watch might not be
matching up with the shows that our
audience watches like I know we have
like a lot of Housewives fans but I
think most of our listeners do not watch
Housewives they just listen to us recap
because they want more show so I'm very
open to the idea of instead of doing
like a TV recap segment adding one more
segment like we have deer toasters you
know I'm always looking for new segment
ideas I love that we recently did
unburden yourselves so that's Monday and
Wednesday maybe we get like a Friday
segment
um we'll have to come up with some good
creative ideas we had judge Jackie a
little while ago I actually have a good
idea for a new segment that came that I
think about all the time when I'm
choosing stories and I just have then
forget about it but to do one story a
day that's like the worst [ __ ]
headline like that's just nonsense and
it's just mindlessness it doesn't have
to be Kelly's but it's like why was this
written who [ __ ] cares just calling
out mindless news where and when you see
it every single day I always love that
Yeah we actually have not done Kelly's
mindless news in so long so that's if we
had quiet
maybe because she knows we're on to her
I think she kind of like stopped she
probably put her PR for month pause
because if there was a lot of Kelly's
mindless news we would have to report it
right and they're just like out here
honestly tarnishing her brand yeah I
actually feel like we might have
affected change not to too darn horn but
it's been really quiet are we like
lobbyists like enacting chain are we
change makers oh my God okay so I like
that idea I'm also open to hearing other
um ideas I don't think that a new
segment should be where people write in
because I think Monday and Wednesday
teeteron being kind of similar sometimes
um so Friday segment would have to be a
little different than that
um I think we had an idea a while ago
but I think it's too similar to Monday
and Wednesday where like yeah no it
doesn't work right like judge Jackie
it's similar to Deer toasters and then
what am I supposed to do for the segment
you know
you bring in the dancing lobsters
that's so me I'm the bailiff you are the
bailiff so I like that idea I also agree
like I find TV Recaps to be kind of
tedious and I don't know that they're
exactly what our audience wants to hear
all the time
yeah and if we don't except for like
when When the Game of Thrones things
come comes back like a major major and
like when there's a new season of
Bridgerton like when there's those
moments we watch as many as we can but
doing like the weekly just TV has
changed the landscape has changed and I
actually feel like if we ever we're not
done doing TV Recaps permanently but now
it's just showed us that like if we
didn't do them it wouldn't be the end of
the world but I do feel like our show
not doing TV apps Recaps would really be
indicative of the changing landscape of
cable especially of Bravo yeah well I
thought that when we stopped watching
The Bachelor like it was gonna like
really affect our numbers in a negative
way and not only has it not done that I
legitimately forgot that there are
people still who still watch The
Bachelor yeah I see headlines sometimes
and I'm just like I can't believe that
this is still going on but then also and
I was feeling this the other day almost
showed a story about Bachelor alums it's
like all the people that we were really
invested in and that we followed and we
were when we were obsessed with the
bachelor so we're like obsessed with
them they're all really like graduating
into new lives new lives and new careers
and it's interesting to see what people
have done to like keep their longevity
in good ways and in bad who are you
referring to I saw that Ashley and Jared
opened up a coffee shop and it's also
Bachelor themed and that's cute for them
yeah no I think about like I always
think about like the OG girlies like
Becca Tilly Amanda Stanton Lauren Lane
and honestly when I I follow all three
of them on Instagram and when I think of
them like I never think of the bachelor
with Lauren obviously think of country
music Becca I think of her podcast and
Haley Kyoko Amanda I think it was like a
bridal girly now she's been like very
Beauty focused over the last couple
years like I literally forget I know
it's really crazy it's it's been a wild
ride also like Nick vile right and and
what I think about a lot is there was a
time where like Bachelor and ABC
ruled reality television like it was
this almost like
superhuman being show like everyone
watched it they were everywhere Good
Morning America you couldn't turn on a
podcast a TV show in the midst of a
Bachelor season without hearing someone
like commentate it on talk about it and
seeing how far they've fallen so quickly
was something I never expected like I
thought that the bachelor would reign
supreme over television till the day I
died yeah even the snatchler has pivoted
right
and I just and now when I see like there
are podcasts or Instagram Pages or just
like things that are very Bachelor
focused I'm like what are you doing
you've gotta you've got a shift you've
gotta evolve yeah what would you say is
the new reality TV
king or queen
oh that's a good question it's tough
because all of these reality shows that
are huge are like flashes in the pan
Love is Blind true but I knew how to
handle of course love Island and love
Island UK right now is making such a big
splash everybody is downloading their
VPN to watch Love Island USA not so much
on peacock they're like paying for
headlines I see them every day like so
and so turned his head it's like I
cannot believe how like
irrelevant love Island USA is like even
last year when I was watching I was
obsessed but I knew like not everyone
was watching I didn't I knew it wasn't
like as big as UK this year with the
shift to Peacock I have not seen one
like organic thing about it yeah organic
being the key word yeah of course it's
easy to like do paid media yeah and like
whoever whatever Publications NBC
Universal owns like they have to talk
about it yeah exactly you know online
NBC News all that eonline has like a
whole vertical dedicated to it because
they're owned by NBC Universal very
upsetting it's very upsetting
um
so yeah what else can I tell you oh I
read a little bit more of Jeanette
McCurdy's book still having such a hard
time getting through it
um and I think
the reason I spoke about yesterday about
it being really dark is part of it but I
also think like when I really sit down
and think about it I'm not like a huge
Jeanette McCurdy fan yeah so I'm not
like you know drinking up every single
word I'm I'm just like not excited about
it but it's still a good book I
understand that but I do think we are
that era like Nickelodeon Disney those
teen stars even though you weren't like
like riding so hard for Sam
that time it was so interesting and and
critical in our lives that I I do think
if you get through the book you'll get a
lot out of it to be able to see that
time through the lens of someone who was
there I also think once I get to the
part in the book
about Nickelodeon like up until now it's
just like child actor Tings and the
child acting space is just like so toxic
you struggle with that in everyone's
book where like before they're famous
you have a hard time caring yes but I
think a really good book makes you care
Jessica Simpson yes okay I thought this
stuff about her childhood in the Bible
Belt was just as interesting as the John
Mayer stuff but she's also
um your birthday buddy so I feel exactly
and I'm a huge fan and I feel like
you're gonna care about your birthday
Buddy's childhood 100
that's just the kind of that of my own
that's the kind of empath that you are
100
um so I will keep you updated I'm hoping
to finish it like this weekend when I'm
touring I read a lot because there's a
lot of downtime so can you read in the
car yes wow you can't because of like
motion sickness no I can't I don't do
anything in the car I don't talk I don't
I can listen to music I just want to
look out the window and just think yeah
you don't scroll on your phone I can't
scroll on my phone I really don't like
chatting either like and I feel like
when I'm in a long hired people think
I'm like mad or something no I just love
looking out the window and just thinking
and pretending you're in a music video
and talking to myself but not having
anything come out of my mouth no not
pretending I'm in a music video because
I'm not like being like extra and mopey
I just I just can zone out do you
pretend you're in a music video when
you're in a window seat on an airplane
no I I don't pretend I'm in a music
video like in my adult life that's not
like where my head goes wow you ain't
living no like as a kid when it's
raining and you're like sitting in the
car Let the Rain Fall Down and wake my
dreams
my sanity yeah but I don't that's not
where my mind goes anymore as an adult
um I wanted to share something with you
okay
so you might have seen this I posted it
on my Instagram story just now but five
years ago today I was on my way home
from Los Angeles and I was in line at
security at LAX and I ran into Tariq El
Moussa and back then five years ago I
knew him because I'm a huge HGTV fan and
I just like was familiar with his show I
wasn't necessarily like a huge fan of
him his family or his show I just knew
him and I thought it was like hilarious
so I took a picture with him and I just
I didn't know that five years later like
I would become
um ataric El Musa historian yeah and I
just want to
um
give the historically accurate version
of that story because I was there oh you
were and I was the one who recognized
him yeah oh my God what were we doing in
L.A the breath in La yeah yeah yeah and
you just totally wrote me out of History
I literally in my mind I was there alone
Olivia was there too Olivia was there
shut up
[Laughter]
oh and did you guys get a pic with him I
don't think so because I recognized him
and I was like that guy looks familiar
but I don't watch HGTV and then like I
was able to make a click but still like
I don't watch HTV HGTV like I don't
really care but you cared and it was
right after the mountain thing
right so I wasn't big in the news I
found it really surprising you don't
watch HGTV yeah you would think that I
would because because it's like very um
like peaceful content yeah maybe if Rach
had a show I would watch
because that's the only kind by the way
rates should have a show her husband
literally does that
that's what the world needs that's the
show I would watch I just I've not seen
I haven't investigated it but I haven't
seen any shows that like are my vibe
well do you ever think about because I
often think about like the show we never
got the show that almost was Scott and
Courtney when he was really into
flipping houses and she was really into
interior design and he wanted to like
work together and she like couldn't even
look at him in the face let alone work
with him and they didn't do it and then
he ended up doing that show with I wanna
be bad will afford yeah make that look
so good uh that show was cute except it
felt pretty staged and I wasn't crazy
about the interior style because it was
very like beachy Malibu and it wasn't
like Rach parcel right it was neither
Rach nor parcel hmm
that's huge that's a huge loss yeah so
someone needs to make that show happen
if they want me to be watching interior
design shows I just think like every now
and then if you flipped on HGTV you
would really enjoy what you saw no but
like a lot of times I'm like in a gym
and it's there's multiple TVs and that's
the closest channel to something I would
care for and still know hmm
still no but I know that there are a lot
of other personalities that like I'm not
familiar with I think there's like a
red-headed woman who people really like
maybe if I saw her I would enjoy it I
don't know
um totally Switching gears but did you
see the trailer that dropped for the
discovery Plus Army Hammer thing it's a
story oh okay good so we should talk
about that yeah and we will
do you want to talk about it now we
could do it soon but I just wanted to
say last night was the season finale of
breaking bread oh right oh sorry what I
was going to say before was when we're
thinking of ideas for segments we had a
lot of good segments in
um breaking bread yeah and I feel like
maybe some of them might work for the
podcast cool but a lot of them require
interactivity yeah interactivity
were you gonna say anything about the
season finale um just that it was very
emotional tears were shed you will be
able to listen to it tomorrow on the
Spotify app and it was last night of
camp and the campers were feeling
emotional it was the last night of Camp
I did kind of signify the end of the
season with a song at the end of the
episode I'm sure Spotify will have to
cut it out um once they put the episode
it would be really easy for them to cut
it out because it was at the end yeah so
I um I don't think you'll be able to
hear it but for those who are lucky
enough to experience it live you're
welcome we'll always have Claudia's
final song
we will I sing I'll always remember us
this way from
A Star is Born which I think is arguably
a better song than cello
yeah
I think so that's my hot take of the day
not that hot
warm lukewarm not offensive you know
you're not gonna stir up any trouble
yeah
she's not a Christian
you still I want Jackie to make that
Tick Tock with me you still haven't sent
me the video I'll send it today because
you have to say four words she could be
a Jew there was one other word though
that that person says okay well figure
it out okay
Pikachu
I'll do it for tick tock because I love
them and they love me until they don't
nah they're not gonna turn on us four
minutes later
okay so I guess without further Ado to
do
oh okay if you guys weren't breaking
bread last night you already know the
breaking news but if you didn't watch
because you were so [ __ ] busy and
like you couldn't swing it
um Theo is under the weather let us know
what's going on so yesterday for like
the morning and the afternoon Theo was
licking his foot Non-Stop and honestly I
was just like so busy I didn't really
pay too much attention to it which I
feel guilty about
um and then I finally like took a look
at it and it looked kind of red and sore
so I got in the bath with him I gave him
a warm bath I scrubbed it clean and when
I was in the bath I was really able to
see like how bad it was and his whole
foot is like inflamed
so I spoke to Dr Lisa Littman Queen like
I was really like so um flustered and
she really calmed me down she called in
an antibiotic an anti-itching pill
medical wipes medical shampoo to clean
it with it all arrived last night he has
to wear a cone because he the licking
makes it so much bad because it's
basically like a bacteria infection
um so he has to stop licking it and last
night before bed I took the cone off to
see if like he would behave and he
immediately went to lick it so he had to
sleep in the cone which was so sad
especially because also I was being the
laziest dog mom but everything was able
to be delivered to me I didn't have a
cone at home you know Petco is on
instacart I love that so I ordered a
cone and I got a size small and a size
medium the size small is like one inch
too small it's like a little too tight
on his neck yeah so then I went to the
medium the medium is enormous and not
only is like the next size like the
necklace size longer but it's taller
like it goes out more he literally
cannot see anything he walks around the
house banging into walls because he
doesn't know what's next to him race
it's been it's been a really hard day
for Thrice and I don't think he will
start feeling the effects of his
anti-itching pill and his antibiotic
until at least tomorrow so he's got a
long road of recovery ahead and he's
hating life with the cone I feel sick I
feel like vomiting I feel like vomiting
too except like I am at peace knowing
like I'm torturing him for his own good
you know
of course but just knowing that Thrice
is in pain and that things aren't peachy
for him
it it breaks the heart like it's
sickening no I was really really bent
out of shape over it last night
um like while I was I was getting ready
I went to Remy's um launch party for
Remy X revolve and honestly I was like
so upset to have left because he had
just taken the meds I'm like what if he
has a seizure like it was tough and
Ben's wasn't home he got home from
Boston late last night but I ended up
going I had a great time by the way
um except for the fact that so it was to
celebrate Remy's line it revolves who
everyone was wearing the line and
everyone was wearing the same dress as
me which normally I don't care about
except for the fact that like the people
there were uh like 19 years old yeah and
they were literal bikini models yeah and
it just like made me
it made me upset
don't let it get you down because you
are looking so good thank you and you
looked great last night but you just
looked great in general so just keep up
the good work thank you so much
some of us are in our jealous wench era
listen as a former a recovering jealous
wench
um I can tell you hashtag it gets better
yeah also I told I gave this update on
breaking bread last night but I'm going
to share it here too which is the
exciting update in my life which is that
I'm starting the process of weaning off
of breastfeeding and pumping and I'm
very it kind of happened naturally
because my Supply went down when I was
moving and I was just like stressed and
missing pump sessions and so now I'm at
a place that now we're doing like solids
purees rice cereal so I don't need as
much milk and so I'm gonna start weaning
so I can get my life back and I'm really
excited and that's exciting for me it's
bittersweet though you know because it's
been so wonderful the breastfeeding
experience so nourishing for rolled he
loves Mama's milk um he does but he's
growing up like and now it's time to
graduate so it is Bittersweet but um
it's pretty sweet and not to make this
about me um I'm just excited because now
I get to feed Harry and of course I've
fed Harry with bottles I find giving a
baby a bottle to be like the most
labor-intensive activity like left arm
has to hold the neck up so like you're
using so much upper arm strength right
arm has the bottle and it's just like
two really uncomfortable arm positions
yeah
so I'm excited too he's gonna be sitting
his ass in a chair and so am I and I can
just like spoon feed him delicious
pureed carrots that his mom made so
perfectly thank you Claudia I got the
puree down we have some nice purees in
the freezer some pureed carrot pureed
potato looks fabulous yeah and it did
you just uh I never wound up using one
of like the fancy baby food machines
like just steaming on the stove and I
use my um blender wait the same blender
that Bruno uses to make Daiquiris for
Magnolia LOL
um
I just realized like I always say and
this is truth like I've literally never
had a carrot
but I guess I have like as a child yeah
you wouldn't eat a carrot now no oh my
God no they're so good it's crazy that
my appetite has regret palette yeah my
palette was more
exploratory and
um open-minded when I was a toddler and
a newborn baby than it is as a 28 year
old yeah
and no if there's a crudite plate like
the only thing I believe in think of
picking up is a cucumber and those are
always the first to go that's so
interesting you should try some of
Harry's carrot puree
so delicious no but like my vision is
definitely
um taking a turn as I get older my
vision is to because I mean I've never
had glasses that I've actually needed
I've like wanted to wear them contacts
or anything but snitch has like really
big prescription and she with her
glasses she sees better than I see
without glasses but like I see good I
just like yeah remember one time there
was something really far off and you
guys were like you can't see that it was
so far away I'm like yeah no sorry I'm
not wearing a magnifying glass well yeah
like as kids Olivia and Margot like from
a very young age we're always like
contacts glasses and honestly I felt so
grateful to not have that burden like
first of all ordering contacts is beyond
expensive okay I agree with that now but
as kids I wanted glasses I would like
intentionally [ __ ] up my eye exams just
to get like a little something so I
could be like the nerd who takes off his
glasses and everybody realizes
yeah of course of course but like in
retrospect it's like an annoying thing
and like at sleepovers you have to bring
your contacts and you can't see anything
when you wake up like it's just it's no
way to live no I'm grateful I didn't
have it of course I'm grateful now but
like at the time that's what I wanted
now I'm like it's so crazy that there
are people who wake up in the morning
and like can't see until they go get
their seeing things in order yeah no
like Olivia yeah
and the snatchler and that's why Lasik
eye surgery is literally life-changing
and I think you and I take for granted
the fact that we wake up in the morning
and we can see that's actually really
true I think a lot of people take it for
granted so if you are someone who's
never needed glasses like acknowledge
your space that you're in yeah also if
you're someone who's never needed braces
no that's like an elite level for sure
none of us have ever had braces but now
people like make fun of our teeth
I don't know they like say we have fangs
oh you know what they're right we do
have fangs I love my things so do I but
um they're not wrong but I just feel
like it's because we watched so much
twilight growing up no that's just like
something cute about us it's like we
don't look alike whatsoever but you know
we're sisters because we all have things
yeah we all have similar noses too yeah
no everyone says we have the same teeth
actually recently and I remember this
happened the last time I lost like a big
amount of weight
um people when I get smaller
always tell me I look like Margo yeah in
your disgraced Queen comedy special it's
Margot ashrae performing really yeah
when you're on
stage and maybe because I'm like further
away from you when I think you look the
most like Margot on stage
and she's a star
thank you I I agree
now I think without further Ado it is
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
stamps.com having to drop what you're
doing to run to the post office
is probably the worst thing on the
planet especially when you have more
important things to do so stop mailing
and shipping the hard way and head to
stamps.com the 24 7 post office that you
can access from anywhere
stamps.com is going to save you time
money and stress for more than 20 years
they've been in indispensable resource
for over a million businesses they give
you access to all the post office and
UPS shipping services that you need
right from your computer you can get
discounts that you can't find anywhere
else like 30 off USPS rates and 86 off
UPS rates so whether you're sending
invoices as an office if you have an
Etsy shop that you're sending products
out or your warehouse shipping orders
you can make mailing and shipping a
breeze because all you need is a regular
computer and a printer nothing special
is required and stamps.com can
seamlessly work with Shopify Amazon Etsy
eBay and more you'll be up and running
in minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send so don't mail and Chip the hard
way sign up for stamps.com today sign up
with the promo code toast for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code toast
great thank you so much our first story
it's a pleasure sorry about that it's
not Friday so I can't give you the space
to do it our first story Army hammers
alleged victims come forward in House of
hammer trailer Army hammers alleged
victims have come forward in the first
trailer for Discovery Plus's new
documentary series House of hammer the
explosive first trailer released
Wednesday by the network includes
footage of two of Hammer's exes coming
forward to detail their harrowing
experiences and include screenshots of
messages and voice notes the star
allegedly sent them in one alleged
message he says I have a fantasy about
having someone prove their love and
devotion and tying them up in a public
place at night and making their body
free use in another voice memo
reportedly sent by him he employs more
violent imagery the three-part series
also features Army's Aunt Casey Hammer
who was the grand daughter of Armond
Hammer the businessman who made the
family fortune in the oil business Casey
says quote I'm about to reveal the Dark
Twisted secrets of the Hammer family
so this spot this um trailer went viral
and I think it's for two reasons
obviously like the army stuff is so
crazy so hearing firsthand from the
victims about what it was like to be
around him is going to be interesting
but also a huge part of the documentary
is something I only recently found out
which is that Armie Hammer comes from
like a very wealthy old school family
um and they're gonna dive into that but
they're also going to dive into like
Army isn't the first man from this
family to be like [ __ ] crazy
interesting and that I believe is what
the ant is discussing got it wow then
it's it sounds like it's going to be
explosive and if it's anything like what
uh lifetime Discovery plus did with R
Kelly documentary it should really cover
the game is Lifetime Discovery Plus
think so I don't
I think so let me see well I was gonna
say this is also a in terms of the
streaming Wars this is a big win for
Discovery plus because I feel like they
really haven't been on like a major
player in the documentary space when it
comes to like celebrity like Jeffrey
Epstein was on Netflix and adelvy was
Netflix fire Festival was Netflix and
Hulu
um Hulu's had some big documentaries
recently and this is like Discovery plus
entering the game officially
yeah I'm trying to figure out if
lifetime is part of Discovery I don't
know why I thought it was Discovery is
like Food Network HGTV Nat Geo it's
lifetime also oh it is yeah
that's right R Kelly that show was
incredible
um
and actually like change the narrative
yeah made a difference yeah so I don't
know what army if he has like any active
charges against him or what but he's
also in the Cayman Islands so right who
knows what will come of it but it looks
so good it's so interesting how like he
went through the Scandal and then he
like disappeared for an entire year and
he's recently resurfaced and now the
documentary like when it rings it pours
because I really haven't thought about
him in so long
yeah
it wasn't that long ago all of this
though
when was it pandemic
I don't remember
and to be honest I feel like when it
comes to like the really gory details
his whole like expose was very detailed
like I feel like we know a lot of it and
I think the stuff that we don't know is
the family stuff yeah because the exes
have shared a lot and also all of the
the his ex-girlfriends like were his
girlfriends while he was married right
that is the part I'm beyond confused
about I'm not sure I'm gonna watch a
documentary because obviously I know
like the allegations against him being
like really violent the cannibalism all
that stuff
um but I'm not entirely sure how all of
it pertains to his marriage agreed um
and the timeline the documentary
premieres on September 2nd so we will be
watching that's not terribly far away
but it's not that close yeah I can't
believe it's almost already September I
know oh my God you know what that means
and actually watching The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills these last
two episodes where it's holiday themed
like it's making me really excited I
love
oh my God wait this is gonna be like
your first holiday season not
potentially seeing snow
yeah I'll be like you does that mean
does that change like the holiday Vibes
people who live in warm weather like I
feel like I quit like as much as a
Christmas tree is a part of Christmas so
is Snow Yeah so is the cold I actually I
know people think like Florida it's
amazing weather you know I prefer
seasons and like me too if I could
choose between New York weather or
Florida weather I would choose New York
weather I'm not I'm not like jazzed
about it being hot all the time I like
fall I like a chill I like I like the
beat fur I like that horse yeah like
it's nice to have like different phases
of your wardrobe to style yeah so I'll
see what people do down here but I do
feel like just like in L.A like people
just dress like it's winter even though
it's 60 degrees let me ask you a
question now that you have like a home
and stuff are you gonna be doing like
Halloween decoration or do you have an
HOA like do you get in trouble for that
I'll have to find out I don't think you
would get in trouble I do think
eventually in my life I'll do stuff like
that not this year I'm just of course
not [ __ ] in busy like pumpkins for
fall pumpkins for fall I don't think
I'll do like spooky I mean I'll probably
just borrow your pajamas like for
Halloween well the HOA will have a
problem with something so scary yeah so
I have to get approval for that I don't
think I like put up actual Halloween
um decorations
I'll do trick-or-treating though oh my
God I forgot that's actually like so fun
yeah
maybe I'll come over oh well you know
what actually I was thinking for
Halloween we can't be separate like I'll
probably have to come down for Halloween
for the Halloween episode yes right we
need to start thinking about who will
and then it's your birthday so I'll
probably just be there that week I
should just schedule a long extended
trip even though I think I have a show
hold on let me just like triple chat no
because we looked it because we talked
about my birthday already and you don't
have a show till like November 12th okay
because we need to start thinking about
Halloween do you have like any ideas
none me neither
I think we should be brass and stress
ah I love that idea by the way and
snitch could be Magnolia totally
um but then we would need to hire paid
actors to be Butters and mystery yeah we
need to get the crew together
one last time I forgot about Halloween
so I'm actually gonna put that in my
calendar like take that week do
Halloween and your birthday love it
can't wait
so exciting okay our next story Olivia
Wilde claims that her ex Jason Sudeikis
meant to embarrass her with the custody
papers served on stage says a report a
lot of custody news coming about coming
out about Olivia Wilde and Jason
Sudeikis as reported like he served her
on stage which was not very terrifying
she also won the first custody battle
against him but in the recent court
documents obtained by Daily Mail she
reportedly accused him of embarrassing
her professionally when she served the
papers during a presentation she was
making on stage during the event in Las
Vegas she said Jason's actions were
clearly intended to threaten me and
catch me off guard he could have served
me discreetly but instead he chose to
serve me in the most aggressive manner
possible the fact that Jason would
embarrass me professionally and put our
personal conflict on public display in
this manner is extremely contrary to our
children's best interests since Jason
has made it clear that we will not be
able to work this out for our children's
sake outside of the court system I filed
a petition for custody in LA
to his credit he responded and said I
understand that the process server had
only done her job however I deeply
regret what happened Olivia's talk was
an important event for Olivia both
professionally and personally and I'm
very very sorry that the incident marred
her special moment he said I did not
want to serviced I did not want service
to take place at the home of Olivia's
current partner because the kids might
be present I did not want service to
take place at the Children's school
because parents might be present
so he said that like the server had
tried and they just knew that that's
where she was going to be that they
would be able to actually get it to her
there and didn't really realize the
implications of doing so yeah no I I
don't think he would like intentionally
humiliate her publicly on such like a
public stage but that doesn't negate the
fact that it happened and that it's
mortifying even though she handled it
like a [ __ ] boss like you know what I
actually think
it might have worked in her favor
because she looked sympathetic like yeah
this is so embarrassing and she handled
it like a total Pro like did not let it
get in the way of her
speech her panel like everything just
went smoothly after that one little
hiccup so I think like nobody's
technically to blame this is just sad
and this is where I feel like first of
all this is like custody this is like a
serious thing it's not like a divorce
filing like this is like kids lives
um and this is where sometimes I feel
like every and I know like it's the law
I guess for a reason but like court
documents like being public like being
accessed so easily like it's just like
sad yeah I agree especially in like a
family court matter yes that's so true
like I don't know some things like when
it comes to criminal someone's getting
pulled over for like a DUI like all that
should be publicly available information
but like why the [ __ ] does it matter to
me
who their kids live with how much of the
time you know yeah
there are I mean sometimes things like
this get sealed but I don't know what
the criteria is for that and obviously
I'm not a lawyer or anything I just feel
like all this like family stuff should
be sealed like automatically yeah I feel
that and maybe it is in different states
um it just feels like wildly invasive to
be reading this yeah
and I just want what's best for the kids
of course
same well she won the first battle so
she's won the battle but will she win
the war I mean she won Harry Styles so
she just wins just everything's winning
which is tough for all of us yeah
sorry
tear
tear next story is a little more custody
news and is it the story that's brought
to you by figs by chance yes
everybody has something they look
forward to in the fall if you're in
healthcare there's something extra
exciting on the horizon which is brand
new fall colors and styles from figs so
if you haven't heard figs makes the
comfiest scrubs around
personally when it comes to Autumn I'm
looking forward to seeing how reach
parcel is decorating her home Halloween
candy
um but the nurses and the healthcare
workers are quaking for the new designs
from figs they are engineered with
Innovative technical Comfort technology
to be ridiculously soft and Incredibly
durable so they make 100 great scrubs
focused on design function and comfort
they are soft they have a proprietary
four-way stretch fabric they are
moisture wicking anti-wrinkle and
anti-odor thanks to silvador
antimicrobial technology some of their
Styles have up to 20 Pockets which is
just fabulous and when we first started
doing reads for figs like our Healthcare
toasters we're quaking saying like first
of all thanks for the code second of all
figs is a life-changing brand and I
obviously got a pair once they started
working for us and like they're also
pajamas they're so comfortable and
stretchy and breathable and I'm like a I
sweat in my sleep I'm always moving so
active so figs are great for anyone but
especially healthcare workers
so if you don't know where to start you
can pick a set in one of their new fall
colors
um they're super popular core scrubs
never go out of style and they're easy
to mix and match so figs believes and so
do we that the awesome humans in
healthcare deserve awesome scrubs to
match head to wherefigs.com and use code
toast to get 15 off your first order
that's
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s.com promo code toast
love it I actually just got a pair of
figs and they're so awesome and they
look so
nice and clean and they fit nice
professional yeah okay next story Kevin
Federline posts videos of Britney Spears
allegedly arguing with their sons
Britney Spears's ex-husband Kevin
Federline not Kevin from the Backstreet
Boys posted a series of old videos
appearing to show the singer arguing
with their two sons k-fed who was
married to the hitmaker from 2004 until
2007 shared three Instagram videos on
Thursday which seemingly showed Spears
scolding her sons Sean and Jaden quote I
cannot sit back and let my sons be
accused in this way after what they've
been through as much as it hurts as we
decided as a family to post these videos
he wrote alongside the clips saying
their sons were 11 and 12 at the time
this was taken he said this isn't even
the worst of it the lies have to stop I
hope our kids can grow up to be better
than this
decision to share the videos online have
sparked outrage with a source in
Britney's Camp telling page six this is
terrible Kevin is disgusting he is
weaponizing the kids by releasing these
videos but in these clips Britney is
just being a mom okay so
um this is like I have a lot of thoughts
because up until this point I haven't
really made a decision on how I feel
about Kevin Federline because yes like I
know a lot of people dislike him because
he like lives off of Britney's money but
for a really long time while Brittany
was really struggling I feel like he was
really there for the kids and so what he
doesn't have a job
it's okay he's a stay-at-home Dad yeah
so up until this point like I I didn't
really understand or agree with like a
lot of people's negative feelings about
him but I feel like
this is so [ __ ] up for so many reasons
first of all
to record someone without their
knowledge in their own home in private
moments and then post on a public
platform when you're famous is so
disgusting and so invasive and I'm never
gonna be a fan of that no matter what's
in the video like I don't like that two
we as a family came to this decision
like
you're the parent like your kids whether
they think you should have posted them
or not like that's [ __ ] Irrelevant
this isn't like their kids right three
the contents of the video like he really
thought he was doing something and I was
ready to see Brittany like pulling her
hair out screaming like teeth being
punched in like these videos were so
like normal like and especially when you
keep in mind that during this time she
was on lithium against her will So Not
only was she like really struggling
mental health-wise she was also being a
parent and I didn't feel like anything
she said in the video was like that
crazy like am I crazy or is that just
like how you get in trouble when you're
a kid yeah I saw the video of them in
the car she's taking the punishment that
she's acting as she's taking away Sean's
phone because he wasn't wearing shoes in
the ice cream store and like I imagine
it's hard to punish teenage boys
especially like she said they're going
through pure beauty and it's actually
the most clear I've ever heard her speak
like Jackie I completely agree her kids
are being disrespectful as [ __ ] in the
back they're also filming her they it
seems like the filming is taking place
from their Purge so they are speaking in
a way that they know is on video where
she doesn't know that she's on video and
that's always like an imbalanced
conversation like that I'm gonna be like
the victim and the other person's just
speaking normal like
at the end of the day she's
be like she's disciplining them and the
and the punishment is you're getting
your phone taken away like there's
nothing really out of the norm there
sure and that's actually like a very
common way of punishing a teenager it
used to happen to us it was the worst
[ __ ] thing on the planet yeah it's
hard to get through to kids like and
that and that's a very fair punishment
and why aren't you wearing shoes in the
in the ice cream store like
that's great it's just that's uh being a
parent like I I agree he thought he did
something even if the videos were more
damning which I don't think that they
are like it's none of our [ __ ]
business everything taken out of context
in this way like yeah we don't even know
like we're just hearing her say like she
wasn't wearing his shoes but we don't
know how he was behaving in the ice
cream store like
without like what the [ __ ] is this and I
agree with you that like I would give
Kevin Federline up until now like I was
like just like you know what like his
job is being a couch potato and raising
these two kids and it always has seemed
like Britney's kids are doing okay so
it's like maybe he's not the worst maybe
at least he's a good dad but this is
[ __ ] disgusting no and like I think
when he posted this like he really
thought he was doing something he would
like change the narrative that Britney's
like a verbally abusive and manipulative
mom and the reaction that I've seen from
people especially people who have kids
is like literally you record me in the
middle of the night coming into my son's
room to reprimand him like
I'm worse
yeah like it it's first of all there's
no context it's really not that bad and
like
people discipline their kids and that's
how she did it I didn't think there was
anything wrong or abusive about it like
she was cursing but the kids are
teenagers and I just I don't know maybe
I grew up in a strict household but I
don't think it's that crazy yeah also
just listening to these videos like it's
clear that they're recording them for
someone you know and for something and I
feel like their dad has
yeah kind of employed them to be like on
his side and they're taking these videos
for him like to show Mom acting crazy no
and the point is [ __ ] twisted of of
him that like he's pitting his kids
again like that because otherwise why
are you taking a video of your mom
yelling at you like what is it are you
proud are you proud you're in trouble
it's extremely manipulative and I think
the point that you made that I didn't
even think of which is literally the
best point is that the kids filming it
knowing it's being recorded makes for an
unbalanced conversation and not a real
accurate representation of how things go
down normally when she's disciplining
her kids because they're behaving
as though people are watching right
right so that's not fair I'm sure
usually when she's giving it to them
they're giving it right they're giving
it right back and even though they were
being recorded they were still like
talking back like in growing up you
didn't talk back like yeah and even
though they knew they were being
recorded they were still talking back a
little bit yeah and that was just that's
kids and then they're also like 11 and
12. they're not bad kids
Federline to release a video of his kids
11 and 12 like acting out that sounds a
personal moment yeah I'm sure the kids
have consented to it because it seems
like they're obviously team dad and
whatever dad wants but that's [ __ ]
shitty too because this doesn't reflect
well on them either and and he should
know that they might think they look
cool and they're talking back to Mom but
he should know that I just think nothing
good ever comes from like exposing like
when people are like posting text
messages or videos like private
conversations being posted publicly
makes the person even if the person who
posted them is in the right which by the
way they never [ __ ] are
it makes the person look like such an
[ __ ] because it's only a thing a true
[ __ ] would do record someone without
their knowledge and share on a public
platform as a famous person it always
makes me think of Bachelor in Paradise
Caitlyn and Blake Kaelyn and Blake like
was like I have to post these to like
save my reputation and he posted them
which just made him look like an [ __ ]
for exposing a girl's drunk text
messages and B they really weren't that
bad and they actually made him look bad
I that's what I thought but I think
other people were just like thought at
vindicating for the tea yeah and I think
Kevin Federline thought he was going to
post these and be completely Vindicated
dad of the year look at my sons
um and now I just like have a hatred for
him which I never had up until this
point and I didn't even agree with a lot
of the hatred he received yeah but no
now it's it's extremely potent on my end
extremely last night I'm breaking Brad
we were talking about the different ways
that we wrap up conversations
and how we like each other and that's on
being a good parent yeah or I'll be like
oh that's so interesting or we'll keep
you updated we'll keep you posted so now
I'm trying to do new ones what did I
just say I don't know it's extremely
potent on my end potent on my end
self-aware
that's out on that
always but I don't think this is this on
that
no and that's on having to discipline
teenagers honestly yeah
our next story like crazy news at page
six exclusive FKA twigs and Margaret
quali are in a nasty argument over ex
Shia LaBeouf's lawsuit that FKA twigs is
suing Shia LaBeouf for alleged sexual
battery assault and infliction of
emotional distress which lasts during
their relationship from 2018 to 2019. so
FKA twigs first spoke about these
allegations in uh interview with L
magazine in September 2021 and actress
Margaret quality who also briefly dated
Shia LaBeouf posted the cover on her
social media with the caption thank you
she Margaret later told Harper's Bazaar
that she posted the cover because it was
important for it was important to me for
her to know that I believe her and it's
as simple as that we're told that after
the piece came out uh FK twigs and
Margaret quality exchanged messages and
FKA twigs hope that Margaret would agree
to be a witness in the case which is set
to go to trial in April 2023 but it
seems that FKA twigs became disappointed
that despite her public show of support
Margaret didn't appear willing to throw
herself into the suit as actively as the
singer had hoped were told the two women
women who didn't know each other before
the L piece was published happened to
run into each other at a hotel in La
recently sources say it's unclear who
approached who but the pair got into an
intense verbal dispute over the matter
in full view of the other Hotel guests
and Margaret's fiancee bleacher singular
Jack Antonoff came to her defense and
joined him with the argument
insiders say that both girls it's giving
Housewives it's giving Ken Vanderpump
getting involved yep it's giving uh
insiders say that both girls were both
left shaken by the incident
well this just sucks because
them fighting like they're both victims
of the same person
um and it's like his abuse continues
because they're now fighting with each
other and I understand fka's frustration
in wanting to build the best possible
case and not having Margaret do the most
but also like you can't force someone to
speak on their trauma like before
they're ready yeah and they say she's
not and it's a lot to act as a witness
in a case such as this and and
Margaret's relationship with him is much
more recent
than fkas and I'm sure whatever it was
that she went through with Shia LaBeouf
is still very much an open wound yeah
and everyone just processes things and
handles things differently and it's
understandable if she doesn't want to
participate but it's also understandable
for FKA frustrated frustrating yeah yeah
but I hope that they can work it out
because they're stronger together than
they are apart yeah agreed I just
thought that was a crazy story no and
like now it's becoming about like them
two being pitted against each other as
opposed to like this man who's [ __ ]
crazy yeah
like let's focus on that yeah that's
Shia LaBeouf is so weird like
I won't lie like holes was amazing but
beyond that like he's been really unwell
for so long I like don't know that much
about him me neither I haven't seen a
piece of his work since he left the
Disney Channel and in my opinion his
catalog went downhill
um it just became like a really serious
actor quickly and then like very bizarre
putting a paper bag over his face like
being very publicly bizarre yeah but
he's in Transformers that's why like
that's why I haven't seen him in that in
that or anything he's a big movie star
from that
well he's also an abuser yeah allegedly
yeah
um okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story
um a little human interest news that I
find personally very interesting and sad
is it the human interest fifth Story
That's brought to you by every plate yes
it is because it's food news as summer
winds down and your schedule gets busy
set yourself up for success with the
ultimate time and money saving hack
every plate
we used to think male kids had to be
expensive but it turns out that every
plate is 25 cheaper than grocery
shopping their quality ingredients come
pre-portioned they help you save money
reduce food waste like literally buying
a bag of spinach and it rots in your
fridge
before you even open it so sad so if
your weekdays or your nights are getting
jam-packed every plate will help you get
delicious meals on your table without
breaking the bank and you can skip your
weekly trip to the grocery store too
so every plate offers options for
everybody which is why we really like it
their menu includes the classic plate a
veggie plate a family plate an easy
plate so you can try whatever it is that
you want without committing to one
preference and then seeing what works
best for you like if you're just
ordering for yourself over if you have
kids in a family like they really have
super customizable options and you'll be
able to find something that works for
you while saving money and eating
delicious food which are two of the
greater things in life
you can also get your first box for just
a dollar and fifty 49 cents oh sorry a
dollar and 49 cents per meal by going to
everyplate.com and entering code
toast149 so get started with every plate
for just a dollar and 49 cents per meal
on your first box but you have to go to
everyplate.com and use the code
toast149 that's toast 149 is the code
everyplate.com
great thank you so much and our fifth
and final story is food news
um and that
it's a sad day
oh no what McDonald's has ended the
mcplant burger test in the U.S
um it didn't go according to plan and
the beyond meat stock has dropped due to
the conclusion of the trial of the
mcplant
um so this is affecting markets wallet
can I say mouths
can I say that in terms of fast food
going plant-based nobody did it better
than impossible burger at Burger King
first of all because it's extremely
delicious second of all they did a huge
marketing push like they were paying
influencers to do a blind taste test of
the impossible versus the regular
Whopper and they really couldn't tell
the difference they had whole
commercials devoted to it and like
McDonald's announced this like mcplant
and then never did any follow-up
marketing on it so I think people maybe
forgot that it was even an option and
just like weren't really advertised
two about this product so like it was a
flop from the beginning because I didn't
feel like there was a huge push behind
it whereas I felt like impossible Burger
almost became like [ __ ] annoying with
how much they were marketing it but like
it became like a staple how you say like
I'll have a Whopper I'll have impossible
Whopper it became like common yeah at
least for me I was really excited about
the mcpund and I've never even had one
either because in the time that they
were trying it which it hasn't been that
long and it's I think it's been about a
year or less I haven't either been to a
McDonald's or been to a McDonald's with
that that had it because
anytime I've gone to a McDonald's in
last year I don't really think I've been
to that many honestly which is
unfortunate for me
um I always ask do you have me plant and
they're like what so it was a trial but
it was like limited run and the people
who would eat it me like never even got
the opportunity to try it meanwhile at
every single Burger King I've ever been
to they're not like making me feel crazy
gaslighting me and the second they
announced it they had it at every
franchise where it's like McDonald's
announced it three years ago and then
like one year ago said all right it's
finally here and then it took forever to
roll out and not even to every location
it was like specific I just feel like
they set it up for failure in the
rollout I don't blame the plant-based
Community I don't know the plant itself
I blame McDonald's to marketing the
rollout and the distribution
I agree completely I think if everyone
followed the Burger King method everyone
would would have had success and I feel
like this is now just like look people
don't want plant-based options but they
actually do but we just don't want it
the way that McDonald's gave it which
was like second-class citizens like an
afterthought yeah yeah
you can try after it was giving you
could try Sears McDonald's you could try
Sears it was giving like
low energy low effort yeah it was like
we want to feel like a part of the
McDonald's experience we don't want to
feel like outliers like we want a happy
new Plant planty meal a hundred percent
we want chicken nugget plants
you know what everywhere not just like
this one burger that we picked out of
the trash can and then we're gonna give
to you no and I feel like now Burger
King is like really the
um leader in plant-based fast food and
they should really expand to like a
chicken nugget I mean that would be well
a Beyond nugget or impossible nugget
that would be so glorious they could
also if anybody wants to contact gardein
they have a delicious chicken nugget
plant maybe for Wendy's maybe by the way
it's it's worth mentioning that like I
don't like
burgers
so I don't really eat burgers
um
and I think the impossible Burger is so
delicious I've had like a couple bites
every time you get it it's extremely
good like it's tasty and for me to say
that the palette of a four-year-old it's
good it's extremely good makes me really
want an impossible Whopper real bad yeah
you should order one or actually you
live in Florida now go get one yeah go
get one because they don't travel well
it's so you also still don't know how to
drive so you'll have to have Zach
chauffeur you to Burger King and you'll
have to bring Harry it'll be a whole
family out date night date night
that sounds like probably the best date
night ever a hundred percent I eat it in
your car yeah no next time we're like
what should we do for dinner driving
around
yeah also Harry got a new car seat that
he doesn't [ __ ] hate so he loves he
does enjoy the brand so it's up a baby
we never had a car seat because we were
just using the Duna because we were just
ubering but now that we have a car he
has a proper car seat and I was I didn't
know what kind of car seat to get
because there are so many they're all so
different but also also similar and like
what's bad what's good I like Panic
ordered a car seat and then I was like
no that's the wrong one and so I finally
ordered the Olivia was like you should
order a car seat that's compatible with
your stroller so I ordered a car seat
that's the same brand as my stroller
that way I don't need a converter I
could just pop it on pop it off so I
ordered the upper baby Mesa car seat and
when it arrived I still like wasn't sure
did I get the right car seat I don't
know how will I ever know and then I
received a sign
because the car seat the shade that was
it was in is called the Bryce the color
the color was called the Bryce I saw it
on the box I was like your honor sold no
further questions and you know I'm
actually a firm believer in like a lot
of this stuff for kids these days is
like so overpriced and like so
Superfluous and like when it comes to a
high chair like people buying that like
fancy one that looks like a spaceship
that cost 500 when literally a Graco one
from Target is 30 and they're the same
thing like but I think one of the things
one of the few things that you should
invest in and splurge on is the car seat
yeah I really like in the beginning I
didn't really buy anything and I
I do regret that there was only so much
I could buy in New York there was only
so much space I had but like really all
of the things that people get like
they the kids really needed and the kids
really enjoy at least Harry like
everything that I bought for him like he
really loves whether it's toys playmats
play gyms like he loves all of it you
know what he doesn't love
that motorized chair
oh the baby Zen
no not baby Zen yo-yo no it like moves
around mamaRoo no there was a he had a
phase where he really enjoyed and it was
a great place to put him but it he's
outgrown it now but that was telling me
that big fancy chair that has like an
electrical dashboard can't figure out a
way for the mobile to move on its own
the mobile to move oh the thing that
goes above yeah that's called the mobile
right yeah yeah yeah that we're talking
about the mamaRoo
yeah like okay so I have to sit there
and spin it when I'm putting him in the
chair because I can't hold him so I need
to get away from him for a second like
yeah it's so dumb it's facts it is facts
but it's also expensive because I just
bought it off of someone's registry yeah
it is expensive but there was a time
where he really did enjoy it and it was
a like now he has is able to play and
like Walkers and also like a thing that
looks like a walk that's just covered
with the legs yeah he feels like a
little Stanley trolley and he loves that
now and so that's what I do and I need a
hands-free option but a few months ago
we did use the mamaRoo yeah because
experiencing obviously childbirth with
Harry for me
um I realize like
when I have kids like what I will need I
will need 55 options for things that can
like be safe in and I don't have to hold
them because honestly it's like very
exhausting yeah no it's really back
breaking and then soon he'll graduate to
a play pen where it's like a little
um area yeah Emily Donato calls it baby
jail that's perfect because like you
know they're safe and you can go into
the other room and take a piss yeah yeah
and just like throw it up with toys and
some grand old time Michaela loves her
little jail cell yeah so it's it's been
a journey but so far I think I got the
right car seat the brass and strass
that's how you know I know that's how I
I literally felt so at peace when I saw
that I said his brother's always with
him you know what it was it was God
Theo's husband talking to you okay but
if Theo's married to God how come he has
an infection on his foot wait
if Theos married to God
does that make me
God's mother-in-law Mary
give me a second oh no it would make my
grandchild Jesus the son of God
yes it would
your God's mother-in-law
and I'm extremely toxic yes you are
nobody's good enough for my son not even
God himself
by the way what's so funny is yesterday
you posted that clip about how when your
kids are 18 like they can [ __ ] scram
um and someone posted in the comments
it's like
you talk a big game but like would you
ever treat Theo that way never
uh okay being totally realistic Theo
depends on me for survival literally
like food water yeah also like you can't
spoil a dog
you know like you could treat Theo like
the king that he is and it really won't
affect it it won't affect how he treats
others like you don't have to worry
about him out in the world but like your
kids you gotta no but discipline like
kids need to need Independence in order
to flourish Theo can be no it doesn't
matter like he could only be so
independent before he dies without me
it's like okay if Theo's like a little
dependent a little this a little spoiled
like it doesn't [ __ ] matter like he
doesn't there's no effect he doesn't
have to go get a job go meet him or a
reality check yeah like it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
right so I don't agree with that and I I
stand by what I said yeah no I agree and
it's [ __ ] hysterical I know I agree
for you I I I don't know what kind of
where I'll be in 18 years in terms of my
I'll probably be yelling at my kids like
Britney Spears like to be honest taking
their phones away taking the phones away
for sure if they even have phones yeah I
can't wait to have that power that's
like what's so cool about growing up
because like as a kid you know a
frequent punishment of ours was getting
like computers or phones taken away and
it was so horrible like powerless like
there was nothing you could do about it
like you were just stuck and I'm gonna
be able to inflict that misery on
someone else
and I'm also going to be able to
not do that you know what I mean you'll
also be able to give it back you could
say I'm gonna take it and then you take
it and you're like don't do it again I
could take it but I won't not this but I
believe you've learned your lesson yeah
no and I took a big game like I'm gonna
be so strict but like literally I can't
even keep the cone on Theo's head for
more than an hour like I'm literally
gonna have monster children who are
spoiled because they walk all over me
you know like I don't see that I don't
see anyone walking all over you wait you
know how like and one of my biggest pet
peeves is people
my age or like at any age that I'm at
being like rude and yelling at their
parents like it's so [ __ ]
disrespectful
um it's one of my biggest pet peeves and
I just think it like speaks so poorly of
my friend if that's my friend doing it
yeah
um
but like I'm gonna be that that parent
like whose kids yells yells at them I
Claudia no one has ever yelled at you in
like in your adult life like uh
sis like you command respect you do no
but like I do feel like I'll be like a
[ __ ] when it comes to Parenting like I
literally birth this child like to yell
at him
no that's the dichotomy that's the
balance you know that's the
the big question in parenting you know
striking the right balance between fear
and love I guess like when I've been
around Michaela I really haven't had a
problem yelling at her like reprimanding
her when she like does something wrong
I'm like no yeah
so maybe I do have it's too important to
get it right obviously it's giving Mommy
Dearest no it's too important to get it
right to make sure that like you raise
you know I know yeah you can't just go
off of like in like you have to really
be thoughtful no I'm not gonna
participate even though like you're
acting wrong yeah yeah no it's important
I feel like it's just really hard yeah
but that parenting is hard yeah that's
like when Theo poops in the house like
that's why there's so many books about
it yeah yeah
I guess we'll just have to wait and see
you know what kind of parent I am we'll
keep you posted because we will be doing
the show for the next 50 years so you'll
find out real quick we will watch this
episode in 10 years and be like you'd
see you fools when one of my kids is
like grounded and I talk about on the
podcast so I had to ground my son and
I'm like really struggling with it and
then someone will send me this episode
yeah and now I'm talking to Future me
okay Charlie
hope you kept the weight off I'm gonna
guess you didn't love that for you
um I hope you're doing well like I hope
you're
you're in a house like I hope you own
your home by then
um I hope everyone is good and healthy
and I love you and I hope you're still
getting Botox and if you're not this is
your reminder to make an appointment
with Dr geeze
yeah oh my God yeah once I stop
breastfeeding and pumping I can get
BOTOX uh and you have to come up here
for it of course yeah we'll go together
I plan a whole trip yeah and then we fun
then I'll be out I'll be a tourist in
New York City I can do all my touristy
things oh my God good and you can go
with Zach because I'm not going with you
and why I see
I'm gonna do things that like I never
did when I lived there like I'm gonna go
to the Met
Empire State Building still no you have
like a thing against the empire state I
don't like heights no I feel that I
don't really like her to see the city
from that church you know I think we
should wrap up today's episode because
I'm counting my blessings that I haven't
been inundated with any noise from
construction there is so much drama here
I haven't even filled to everyone and
I'm like going back and forth with the
building management it's just I figured
out that we've had a construction zone
outside of our studio since May 2021 I
like went back and watched episodes and
saw when this there was an episode with
Taylor strecker and all of a sudden
there was a scaffolding up I wasn't
there that day but I remember like all
of a sudden and we've been very good
tenants I really haven't complained
about it I haven't asked for a rent
abatement or anything but seriously I
can't imagine what they're doing needs
to take more than 15 months
yeah so I've been I'm grateful for today
they didn't bother me
um
and they were trying to be helpful the
management they're like let me know if
there's like a special episode and we
can like tell them to stop but like
otherwise we have to keep going I'm like
every episode especially you never know
when creativity will strike it's so true
every episode is special I'm like that's
like saying one child is more special
than another you know yeah no but
there's there's every episode is special
but there's definitely like one one out
of 30 that's like
yeah of course but we can't predict
which ones that's going to be and
schedule the construction to not be
there no no no no
no no no no no so that is our show so
exciting that the next show you listen
to will be Fridays because tomorrow's
Friday it's also my uh first show back
on tour so if you want to come see me on
tour girl with no job.com tour tickets
available to New York shows New Jersey
shows North Carolina shows Alabama shows
Portland shows Seattle shows come see me
on tour it's hilarious you're gonna have
a great time and you'll get like wasted
and just be around like-minded people
which is always fun girl with no job.com
tour
that's all we got for you that's all she
wrote pencils down everyone pencils down
blue books
closed thank you so much for listening
to the morning testimony Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast pretty much
anywhere podcast can be found on Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio iHeartRadio
I don't know of a place where you can
listen to podcasts where you can't find
ours but let me know that's true but
don't don't tempt anyone to take us oh
my the construction's here goodbye
everybody have a great day
foreign